all right Chris
how you doing man Chris where'd you grow
up where are you from originally I'm
from Malay California I I stay right now
in Compton area 120th and Central I work
at Certified mechanic
I went to school guy you know how's your
family like growing up
uh it was pretty uh my mom and dad they
were together until I was 18 and then
who wants to turn 18 they separated it's
kind of like weird but how would you
describe your childhood with your family
[Music]
um
a little bit rough
who'd you get along with better mom or
dad
my dad
yeah
when I haven't talked to him like more
than two years
graduate high school yes sir
you've been an auto mechanic since then
yes
I I learned auto mechanics on my dad
it's I love to you know like anything
has to do with engines I love
I love the subject auto mechanic you
know I have a lot of patience for it
I'll put a whole engine apart and put it
all back together
it's great thank you
how old are you now I'm 33 33. yes sir
you've been married before no never
married you have kids I don't I got I
got daughters
are you racing them or are you in their
lives uh they're not with me
being all kind of complicated situation
my kids went back with my
baby Mama's mom
Grandma I mean it's kind of like
difficult but you know
do you like to go down to Figaro Street
and yeah pick up the ladies sometimes
yes sir tell me about that
I'm going I'm going like three or four
times a week there's a lot to choose
from down there I know
I like Mexican Latin
I like them short you know
what's great about Figaro Street I guess
it's great about women in general
there's some there's something for
everybody oh yes I like white chicks too
though
pretty good
it's funny how certain guys would like a
certain type and other ones
you'll see a girl that's like drop dead
gorgeous and everyone like 10 cars will
Cruise past her not even talk exactly
it's kind of funny like seeing them just
like
seeing one girl like you know like in a
corner and you have about like 20 30
cars waiting and they're not even like
in the rush they have so much passion a
passion for each car to actually get
their chance and you know what I mean
it's a crazy scene it reminds me of
like like a Superstore yeah yeah
especially like it Peaks out around two
in the morning right exactly yeah
everywhere else is like every other
neighborhood is quiet and everyone's
sleeping hey exactly two or three in the
morning it's a circus yeah exactly it's
fun I I like to pick them up and
I like to watch them because it's like
it's amusing you know it's beautiful
girls oh yeah absolutely gorgeous of
course
how long you been doing that
I like
10 years
I'm sure you have some crazy stories oh
yes
Steven rod
uh no I've been getting that before
you've been kidnapped how'd that happen
it was crazy because this this chick
just told me like I'm not gonna let you
go I'm like she's literally was giving
me hostage in the house and
I started getting paranoid and then I
told her like hey let's go buy some
cigarettes and she was like okay but I'm
gonna go with you like oh that's what
I'm asking is go buy some and so as
we're walking down the stairs I jump in
uh I had a BMW back then
and you know when the BMW you unlock it
it unlocks just the driver door then you
gotta press it twice to unlock the
passenger door so I unlock it the first
time I jump in my car and I smash then
this chick just throws a big ass bottle
right behind my car
next thing you know she's texting me
thanks a lot I like why my cousin beat
the [__] out of me she was just whopping
out you know
they're Hustlers yeah have these kind of
relationships that you have with these
women got in the way of you having a
real relationship with a girl that might
actually offer like a long-term loving
relationship I don't feel that I'm ready
for something like that but the day that
comes you know I'll I'll find that one
and I'll settle down I don't mind I've
been
with so many girls is you know what I
mean I'm not thinking about settling
down or marriage but it's just I I'm I'm
good you think you're addicted to this
Supermarket of yeah
pretty sure I am it's gonna be hard for
you to settle down with one after you
exactly you stand for a different one
every I remember a teacher told me Chris
are you sure you just want to eat that
steak your whole entire life I was 13
years old when I had my first kid my
first baby mama about 13 14. my my
daughter right now she's about to be 17.
wow that's early no I know and that's
what she told me and then it left me
thinking like oh my goodness what did I
do but I got beautiful kids man I could
say that do you ever developed feelings
for any of these girls that you've
gotten involved with yeah I have treated
some of them they always treated me with
respect and sister love you know what I
mean some of them are very nice yeah
some of them personalities exactly and
some of them are pretty mean they'll
freaking like try to like get you out
what do you think of the fact that most
pretty much all of them have pimps
hiding somewhere in the background that
right there is I mean
each every each every one of them
with their own
you know set of set of Minds
because
anything go down at any time it's really
just a hustle yeah it's really just a
way for the girl to make money
exactly
she thought she could do better by
robbing you with a gun she'd do that but
instead oh yeah she does this thanks
Frankie you're pretty successful at it
yeah
it's crazy you know are drugs a part of
your life are drugs a part of your life
uh yeah I had been doing Mr fatimeters
ever since I was 12. oh really
yeah I don't feel that has affected me
that much in life but yeah I have lost
so many things and I gained so many
things uh you know it's just I take it
like a way to
pick yourself uh pick yourself back up
have that knowledge that that strength
to race yourself back up you probably
work hard when you're honest exactly as
long as you don't get too
heavily into it right exactly
and does it
play a part in when you go down to Fig
and pick up a girl
yeah pretty much I I I love to
be in death and like a set of mind when
I'm actually with someone I don't really
like to be normal it's not enjoyable
yeah drugs in Figaro Street kind of go
hand in hand
yeah it's it's a lot in there's a lot of
things that could kill you too though
you know
you worry about STDs at all
I always have chicken myself I've always
been cleaning and everything yes it
worries me because I mean gosh
that's a lot that's a lot of freaking
diseases out in days you know like this
season's day here you know the meaning
of it you know
you've never caught anything no
you think humans are meant to be
monogamous
[Music]
but having all these different partners
is just something you
prefer at this point in your life
yeah I mean at the end of the day We Are
Who We Are
you know
if it bugs you it's gonna bug you if it
doesn't why
I remember I remember a teacher when I
was in high school he asked me
will you want your girlfriend or wife to
be at home the whole entire time or we
want her to go make some money
I told her as long as she's bringing
that bread at home I ain't tripping what
she's doing you know what I mean it's
that's the way I am
if you're
wife or girlfriend was
going down to Fig to make some money
you'd be cool with that no I mean
yeah I prefer them to be honest with me
instead of me finding out
my honest it takes a long way
loyalty does too
love love is just a word because someone
can always stab you in the back and say
they love you you know
Chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
wear a condo
[Music]
what should I say
[Laughter]
you know better be safe than sorry Chris
thank you so much for sharing your story
appreciate you man wish you lots of luck
thank you